[Music]
my name is David gloriam I worked at
this department or drug designer
pharmacology at universe Copenhagen as
an associate professor and group leader
I also happen to be the head of a
research database we did my field of
research in my work we do
interdisciplinary projects relating
about identifying drugs or drug like
substances of course I'm interested in
publishing open access because that
means that more researchers will be able
to read my articles
that was generated for citations which
is very important Mary's for me my
interesting inner process is forced make
my research availability to as many
other researches possible but this is
also encouraged who were more by
foundations and many of the EU grants
require open access and also I think
today in a national Danish and funding
and we encourage your astrology yes I
think that both Denmark as well as the
University of Copenhagen where work
would benefit a lot from publishing open
access because that would generate a lot
more disability and traction to to our
articles and that would promote the
Denmark and University in the
international competition I see a lot of
value in this of course because as a
researcher we are mainly funded by tax
payers money and the society should know
that they get something back from their
investment I think open access benefits
everyone but I think it's extra
important for union researchers I think
that the obvious
challenge is
that of the cost so many more
researchers want to publish open access
but they cannot afford so there can be
so many different solutions to this
either the University will pay or
someone on the national level that want
to promote their institution
alternatively foundations should
continue the trend of requiring open
access and also supply the money to
publish open access and I think there's
a lot to gain from the foundations to
make the result from the public's more
available for me publishing open access
and also using social media more it's
been a bad consciousness for me and a
group for a number of years
it's an one of the things that I know is
very important to do but we haven't
found the time now I think we can't
afford not taking the time
[Music]